hey wait i got to do something right now
right while i have a chance so sal's in
the studio with gary
uh-huh sal thinks it's election day he
thinks it's the national election so i'm
going to call him and i'm just going to
talk to him and ask him who he's voting
for tomorrow
all right so hold on a sec tell gary you
can bring in sal he has no clue just
listen to this
[Laughter]
anyway um so who are you voting for
tomorrow in the election
uh mccain you're voting for mccain yeah
you know
i was saying this one the other day i
said i don't even know if sal knows that
tomorrow's election day
i'm going to the post office today to
register you're registering today today
for the vote tomorrow yeah i guess
i guess so who's right first of all i'm
proud of you this is the first time i'm
proud
so interested in mccain being president
you're gonna register
yeah i'm impressed how did you learn it
was election day tomorrow
i don't know i thought we would have the
day off and i just uh to tell you the
truth i had a feeling it was tomorrow
because
on the news i guess it's coming down to
the wire so who is running right now for
president
how could be mccain barack obama and
hillary clinton that's it for
i guess okay now after tomorrow
how soon do they become president
immediately
immediately well okay they have to tally
the votes right and the votes come
through
and then they based on the votes they
decide who so tomorrow's election day so
you're saying uh by
by tomorrow night we'll know who the new
president is yeah you know how you get
the rap on the radio that you're like
an idiot you don't read the paper and
you don't know what's going on for once
you [ __ ] know what's going on you're
with it and you're taking responsibility
i i have a feeling you're being
facetious with me how will we know who's
the vice president
tomorrow well from what i heard
i think that uh
they kind of group together let's say
like barack loses hillary might take on
barack as the vice president
right something like that well so in
other words whoever loses gets to be
vice versa
maybe but i think why are you voting for
mccain well how did you come to that
conclusion well
i like that he's not hillary or obama
okay he's a guy
he's a man's man you know and why not
huckabee
i don't know anything about him oh okay
but the last name's a little corny
you know president huckabee you couldn't
go with that you're blaming him for his
last name i mean sounds like that
restaurant applebee's exactly i mean
europe is laughing at us enough
so tomorrow where are you going to vote
uh i go to the post office and then i
think you go to the
you can vote at the schools at the
school so you'll go to what your kids
school and vote yeah
okay why don't you take your kids a lot
of people take their kids with them when
they vote yeah why don't you take the
kids so they can see your vote
i'm trying to do something right in the
past you know you guys chastise me for
not uh
voting i think your kids will honestly
i'm being
coming from the heart i think your kids
will be proud tomorrow when you walk
into the school
and it's a great city and they can sit
there and go my dad's here to vote
right you know i think they're gonna
really like it well on wednesday we will
have a new president sal is right about
that once they tally up the vote
and as soon as we know who's second they
can be the vice president well tomorrow
we'll see who wins
okay good luck all right thanks who's
gonna be the next president
well we'll know by tomorrow night did he
ask his wife if she was voting she's
voting him out of the house